former President Bill Clinton is
addressing the affair he had with Monica
Lewinsky 25 years ago the revelations
are part of a new Hulu docu-series out
today titled Hillary in it mr. Clinton
acknowledges the relationship he had
with Lewinsky was out of line
take a listen everybody's life has
pressures and disappointments and
terrors fears of whatever things I did
to manage my anxieties for years I'm a
different totally different person I
look he goes on to say it's not a
defense for the affair it's an
explanation still no apology though is
there in that documentary says he feels
terrible but no but he said it was
something about him handling his anxiety
I mean I just number one I'm sorry to
hear that because I just think that kind
of thing should have been reserved for
your closest friends and for me my heart
goes out to Monica Lewinsky again yeah I
mean she was 21 22 she's now
40-something she's smart she's funny
she's kind she's lovely but she still
has this baggage that is tied to her
while everyone else is sort of tiptoe
through the tulips she's still stuck
with this and it just seems so unfair to
me about her and when I said no apology
I meant no apology to my not addressing
the fundamental power imbalance right in
the President of the United States and
when a in when a one-year-old yeah
regardless of anxiety or the stress that
you feel because you hold that office a
22 year old intern yes yeah and once
again minimizes marginalizes her it was
wrong on all parts but it just I hear
that and my heart goes out to her